podcast go watch the whole interview
with this guy gorilla names his new
album is out rise of the Silverback
go get it fully produced by scram Jones
that's a fat it's out right now man you
know we gotta make a uh what would we
call this or did it tradition yeah facts
play a [__] beat go let's go some
West Coast [__] okay
[__] your life we outside you heard rise
of the Silverback out right now
ah yeah foreign
[Music]
10 years ago and you failed in life
[__] your life man
life
something light yeah on a Tuesday I'm
freestyled out bro I'm [__] doing
freestyles every [__] day over here
come on Nims you know we got to do the
boot we got you man come on man rise of
the Silverback out now
I appreciate you guys watching this
freestyle we got another one coming and
then another one and then another one
and they're all brought to you by our
good Folks at LRG clothing you already
know what it is LRG been keeping you fly
for years they got so much new fly gear
right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30 off
l-r-g.com another freestyle's on the way
presented by LRG